اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم نتنياهو يعلن تمسكه
بالحرب وم عائلات الاسرى بتاخير استعاده
ابنائهم عبر المظاهرات وينتقد الاصوات
الاسرائيليه المشكك في الانتصار وذلك وسط
احتجاجات في تل ابيب وحيفا تهاجمه وتطالب
باستقالته وبصف لاستعاده الاسرى وتجدون
المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق
الاول عدد النازح حين بسبب الصراع الدائر
في السودان وصل الى 10 ملايين و700 ال شخص
منذ منتصف ابريل نيسان الماضي المنظمه
الدوليه للهجره وصفت هذا الرقم بالصاعق
ودعت الى بدل جهود دوليه مكثفه لتعزيز
الاستجابه الانسانيه بشكل عاجل لما وصفتها
باكبر حاله نزوح في
العالم كوريا الجنوبيه تقول ان جارتها
الشماليه اطلقت عده صواريخ كروز قباله
ساحلها الشرقي في ثاني عمليه اطلاق من
نوعها في اقل من اسبوع حيث كانت كوريا
الشماليه قد افادت بان اطلاق الجيل الجديد
من صواريخ كروز يعد امتدادا لعمليه تحديث
نظام الاسلحه
لديها مقتل شخص في هجوم مسلح على كنييسه
سانتا ماريا بمنطقه سراير في اسطنبول خلال
قداس الاحد السلطات التركيه اعلنت فتح
تحقيق في الحادثه لمتابعه ملابساتها
والجهه التي تقف خلفها وقالت انها تتابع
تحقيقاتها لالقاء القبض على المنفذين الى
اللقاء